[Music]
Sunday's episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians had plenty of drama centered
around Caitlyn Jenner's controversial
memoir I'm telling it I come for you but
it also had a few light-hearted moments
specifically some awkward stories about
Rob Kardashian's sex life when you the
girl that won the Kim Kardashian
look-alike contest
wait what when you the girl that won the
Kim Kardashian look-alike contest
oh I thought you were talking about the
girl that pulled up to your house and
she was like butt naked and then I went
upstairs have sex then she period it all
over in the bed was like and then was
like oh like and we were completely fine
with it and then she just left after
yeah we're not entirely sure what to
make of that interesting trip down
memory lane but then things got even
more weird here's what happened when
Khloe made Rob experience what it feels
like to have menstrual cramps apparently
my period cramp device worked and it's
not that I want my brother to endure
pain but I want him to know what I have
to go through every single month gotta
love Keeping Up with the Kardashians
always keeping us on our toes
you
[Music]